Searching through the review aggregator site
Metacritic, you’ll find reviews for thousands
of games.
But there are thirty-one games that stand
alone, with rankings head and shoulders above
the rest.
These are the only near-perfect games out
there, according to the rankings on Metacritic.
It should surprise no one that Rockstar is
going to be a part of any conversation involving
the greatest games of all time.
The Grand Theft Auto Double Pack is a bit
of a cheat since it's two games, but it makes
sense.
Collect two already great games into one package,
and you’ll make magic happen.
The content in this rerelease of Grand Theft
Auto 3 and Grand Theft Auto: Vice City was
nothing new, but the graphics were given a
serious once-over to be at their absolute
best for the era.
Many of the reviews are no longer available,
but reading the critic review quotes on Metacritic
is eye-opening for the joys of yesteryear.
One reviewer wrote that ensuring you had 480p
television capabilities would make for the
"prettiest GTA experience you'll get on a
console."
Ah, 2003.
At the time, this was the cleanest and most
stable version of both these games available.
It isn't surprising that having the best versions
of these two already great games rolled into
one release was something to get excited about.
One of the great gaming bait-and-switches
of all time made for one of the PS2's most
memorable games.
Metal Gear Solid 2: Sons of Liberty ticked
a lot of people off when it launched, as Metal
Gear Solid fans had no idea they would not
be playing as the grizzled protagonist Solid
Snake for most of the mission.
Even though the game got a lot of love, new
protagonist Raiden received a lot of ire from
fans.
Though he's earned back a lot of goodwill
in the time since.
Metal Gear Solid 2 took the exciting stealth
gameplay of the original and cranked it up
with the power of the PS2.
The technological achievements of the game
were completely amazing, with some websites
calling it "something that looks as close
to real life as it gets on your TV."
This was also the entry in the series where
Hideo Kojima really got to flex his storytelling
muscles to create a memorable narrative.
Gran Turismo is one of the oldest games on
this list; it was released for the original
PlayStation back in 1998.
The battle between the disc-based PlayStation
and the cartridge-based Nintendo 64 was in
full swing, and Gran Turismo helped showcase
something that the N64 couldn't do: Total
realism.
Gran Turismo was like a glimpse into the future,
as you could seemingly design every element
of your car and take it through photo-realistic
races.
Reviews lauded the game's customization, attention
to detail, and multiple ways to race.
About the only knock on the original Gran
Turismo was the licensing aspect.
The game tasked players with earning licenses
by completing difficult driving tasks before
entering higher-level races.
Considering how badly you'd lose a race if
you couldn't pass these tests, it's a rather
small knock.
You knew Link was going to show up on here.
The Legend of Zelda: The Wind Waker is probably
one of the lesser-played titles in the series,
simply because it was originally released
on the GameCube.
It still featured the same great combination
of combat, puzzles, and exploration that the
Legend of Zelda series is known for, however.
It also boasted one of the most striking visual
styles the series has ever adopted.
The Wind Waker utilized a cel-shaded graphic
style to appear as if it were a cartoon come
to life, but the game used its exaggerated
visuals to tell a deep and emotional story.
It also made great use of its beautiful art
direction with its sailing sections, where
Link would hop on a boat and traverse between
islands.
Even two decades after The Wind Waker's release,
it's absolutely gorgeous to look at.
The Wind Waker may have suffered due to its
platform, but it still holds on as one of
the strongest entries in a consistently strong
series of games.
Luckily, an HD remaster was released later
on so a wider audience could play the game.
Unfortunately, that platform was the Wii U.
A phrase you often hear tossed around with
incredible games is that they "revolutionize
the genre."
A lot of games on this list could probably
claim they achieved this lofty goal, but Half-Life
might have the best claim to it.
Many other genres have moved past their classic
roots, but shooters still get compared to
Valve's darling, even though it was released
over two decades ago.
Half-Life follows the voiceless protagonist
Gordon Freeman as he battles human and inter-dimensional
enemies through the Black Mesa research facility.
It has been described as "the definitive single-player
game in a first-person shooter" and "the closest
thing to a revolutionary step the genre has
ever taken."
It's hard to believe that the fifth Elder
Scrolls title was released all the way back
in 2011.
There have been so many different versions,
mods, rereleases, and ports that it would
be easy to guess the game "released" just
a few years ago.
It regularly sits in the top half of Steam's
player count lists, an impressive feat for
a decade-old game that has no multiplayer
to speak of.
Skyrim puts players into the role of the Dragonborn,
a legendary warrior with the ability to learn
powerful, magical abilities.
"Su'um ahrk morah.
You will push the world harder than it pushes
back."
More importantly than that, it gives aspiring
adventurers a playground to run wild in, flexing
their role-playing muscles and providing a
near limitless way to approach character building
and questing.
The AV Club summed it up nicely in its review,
saying.
"[Skyrim helps players] feel like the game
is happening to them, and they are alive in
it—not just cogs in a pre-fab game experience.
That's what sets Skyrim apart from some of
its contemporaries."
You could argue that this is a concept that
every open world game sets out to achieve,
but few truly do.
One of the last major releases for the GameCube
was one of its most beloved.
The Legend of Zelda: Twilight Princess also
released as a launch title for the Wii, and
both versions have fans who swear "their"
version of the game is the superior one.
Twilight Princess saw Link attempting to save
Hyrule from becoming overtaken by another
dimension called the Twilight Realm.
The player could shift back and forth between
the two dimensions, and Link could also transform
into a powerful wolf for a host of new abilities.
The Legend of Zelda games tend to land in
one of two camps.
They are either experimental in many of their
design choices, or they attempt to perfect
elements of past games.
Twilight Princess may fall into that latter
category.
It's lauded for its dark, engrossing story
and cinematic style, and is often compared
to other heavy-hitters in the franchise like
Ocarina of Time.
It may not have taken many big risks, but
it absolutely nailed what it set out to do.
The Mass Effect series is frequently heralded
as a tremendous bit of modern gaming, and
almost any fan of BioWare's space opera RPG
will tell you that Mass Effect 2 is the best
entry in the series.
You could probably make a strong argument
that the reason Mass Effect 3 released to
such a negative response was because the second
game set the bar far too high.
A lot of story-driven games get knocked because
your decisions ultimately don't affect the
outcome beyond the surface level.
That is absolutely not the case in Mass Effect
2.
The choices you make, the quests you go on
throughout the game's extended runtime, the
way you play, and the strategic options you
choose in the game's climax can all have huge
repercussions on the way things play out.
It's fascinating reading about the different
endings people see and which crew members
don't make it out of the final mission alive.
Few games truly give you that level of ownership,
and it's hard to think of any that do it as
well as Mass Effect 2.
The intricacies and mechanics of every fighting
game take a massive amount of skill and hours
of practice to crack.
While games like Street Fighter, Mortal Kombat,
Super Smash Bros. , and more all have pro
scenes and complex webs of mechanics to master,
few major fighting franchises are as complex
as Tekken, and few games are as revered in
their franchises as Tekken 3.
Like any fighting game worth its salt, Tekken
3 had an absolutely bananas storyline involving
demons, corporations, and, of course, a fighting
tournament that determines the fate of the
world.
More importantly, it has a diverse cast of
balanced characters to go along with a deep
and impressive combo system and move list.
It also looks and feels great.
Tekken 2 was a masterpiece as well, and the
second and third entries are still considered
the best the series ever put on offer.
Many reviewers felt that the complete console
version of Tekken 3 is actually a better experience
than its arcade counterpart.
The Arkham franchise helped redefine open
world action games and created what many think
of as one of the best superhero games of all
time in the process.
Even Arkham's less-than-stellar efforts were
a lot of fun to play, but many would argue
that Batman: Arkham City is the crowning achievement
of the franchise.
Arkham City allowed gamers to truly immerse
themselves in the role of the Dark Knight.
The rush from swinging among familiar Gotham
City landmarks, beating down dozens of foes
at once with elaborate, but simple to perform,
combos, and taking on a colorful rogue's gallery
was all part of the fun.
The big names like Joker, Penguin, Riddler,
and Mr. Freeze are all here, alongside deeper
cuts like Solomon Grundy and Victor Zsasz.
Reviewers called Batman: Arkham City the best
licensed video game ever made, and nearly
every review commended it for one-upping its
already beloved predecessor, Arkham Asylum,
in almost every way.
The Orange Box might just represent the greatest
collection of games ever put together.
This incredible collection packed in five
games, and all are still held in fairly high
regard.
The original Half-Life was heralded as one
of the most important games of all time, and
its sequel improved upon it in almost every
way.
Half-Life 2 itself would have been part of
this list, but its inclusion in The Orange
Box made that a little redundant.
Half-Life 2: Episode One was included here
as a bridge to Episode Two, which was first
released as part of The Orange Box.
It's probably the weakest of the five included
games, though it is still pretty impressive.
Half-Life 2: Episode Two served as the big
draw for many gamers with The Orange Box,
seeing as this was how the episode debuted.
Years and years later, fans are still clamoring
for Episode Three.
Team Fortress 2 was one of Valve's biggest
moneymakers, and continues to be one of the
most popular shooters in the world.
Finally, Portal made it into the bundle.
What seemed like a throwaway tech demo actually
proved to be one of the most influential games
of all time.
Most gamers who were around in the GameCube
era have some memory of Resident Evil 4.
The opening action scene, where Leon is attacked
by a group of villagers armed with farming
equipment, and one seriously pissed-off guy
with a chainsaw, is one of the most memorable
action scenes of all time.
The Resident Evil series was well-loved but
a bit fiddly up until this point.
"Jill, here's a lockpick.
It might be handy if you, the Master of Unlocking,
take it with you."
A lot of the tension in the original three
games derived from the tank-like controls
that made quick escapes almost impossible.
Resident Evil 4 changed all that, veering
into more traditional control territory while
still maintaining the tense and terrifying
atmosphere.
The story is still nonsensical in a delightful
B-Movie way, but it all adds to the game's
charm.
Reviewers often discussed how the game set
the benchmark for the series on its original
release on the GameCube.
A few elements are a bit wonky, but Resident
Evil 4 still holds up.
Uncharted 2: Among Thieves is one of the most
surprising entries on this list.
Not because it isn't an incredible game, but
because it isn't typically a franchise that
gets mentioned in the all-time greats.
That suits the game's tone just fine.
A wild adventure with a compelling multiplayer
mode and plenty of opportunities to make your
own carnage, Uncharted 2 is a near-perfect
adventure that really showcases what the best
video games can do.
Reviewers often comment that the attention
to detail is beyond compare and that the game
is an essential experience.
PlayStation Universe said,
"[It's] quite possibly the best game to have
graced the PS3, and without a doubt one of
the greatest titles ever conceived."
Much of the attention surrounding Among Thieves
is that it just feels like an action movie.
It's cinematic, but you always feel in control.
It's a game that lets players live as Indiana
Jones and their other favorite adventurers,
and that's reason enough to put it so high
on the all-time greats list.
The Nintendo 64 has more than its fair share
of nostalgia bombs, but few hold a candle
to GoldenEye 007.
Part of its hold on the collective gaming
consciousness has to do with the fact that
some odd licensing disputes have made any
sort of rerelease or remaster of GoldenEye
dead in the water, so the only way to play
it outside of ROMs is in its original Nintendo
64 form.
It can be easy to forget that one of the big
draws for the game at the time was the single-player
mode.
Licensed games were, and still are, often
seen as cash grabs, but GoldenEye did a great
job of translating aspects of the film into
a fun and coherent game.
What most people remember, however, is the
game's multiplayer.
The four-person, split-screen experience ate
away the hours as players screen-sniped and
golden-gunned one another.
GoldenEye remains a masterpiece as both a
console shooter and a couch-multiplayer legend.
In hindsight, BioShock seems like a surefire
hit, but the game was a pretty big risk at
the time.
An entirely original IP with a strange art
style, no multiplayer to speak of, and a cerebral
storyline about ethics crammed into a first-person
shooter?
It was no sure thing.
Luckily, BioShock was beautifully put together
and planned, and its unique creative direction
drew people in who were tired of outer space
and World War 2 shooters.
Nearly every aspect of BioShock was praised
for pushing boundaries and perfect execution.
Even if certain mechanics seem typical by
today’s standards, BioShock helped pave
the way for elements like combat customization
and stealth.
The story was also incredible, and the big
twist has become the stuff of legend.
About the only knock against BioShock is the
final boss battle, something that even the
game's designers have said was a mistake.
"A man chooses.
A slave obeys."
Back in the day, the rivalry between the Madden
and 2K Football franchises was intense.
Each side had supporters, with Madden often
coming out on top due to familiarity and market
saturation, and eventually, completely knocking
its competitor out of the game.
However, purists were often bigger fans of
2K, with NFL 2K1 often being highlighted as
the franchise at its absolute best.
2K1 improved on the previous year's also stellar
entry by introducing some major improvements.
It included better animations and artificial
intelligence as well as totally revamping
the running game.
NFL 2K1 also introduced one of the most important
gaming features of all time: Online multiplayer.
It was the first sports game that let you
find opponents online, something that's tough
to imagine any competitive game going without
these days.
The Xbox had powerful specs when it hit the
scene in November 2001, but it needed something
extra to make a mark against the vast catalog
of games in Sony and Nintendo's stables.
It had just the thing in Halo: Combat Evolved.
Halo was a sci-fi shooter that captured so
many of the best elements of the games before
it.
It featured an incredible single-player campaign
full of cinematic missions and an epic storyline.
It had memorable characters and graphics that
made it stand out as a must-see video game.
On top of all that, it had near limitless
gameplay due to its intense multiplayer options,
giving players all sorts of ways to have late
night frag sessions and white-knuckle competitive
matches.
It's not hyperbolic to suggest that Microsoft's
console foray may not have found its footing
if it weren't for Halo: Combat Evolved.
It's about time the world's most famous plumber
made the list.
And you could probably pick from about a dozen
entries in this incredibly long-lived series
as the "best" and make a compelling case.
Super Mario Odyssey for the Nintendo Switch
towers above them all, making perfect use
of the hardware to combine all the best aspects
of past Mario games.
If you've got a Switch and haven't played
it, you're missing out.
Super Mario Odyssey's central sticking point
is Cappy, a sentient piece of headwear that
gives Mario the ability to take control of
enemies and use their special abilities.
This capability makes for a seemingly infinite
number of fun and hilarious combinations to
solve the game's puzzles, and it's extremely
easy to just get lost in messing around with
the different abilities at your disposal.
Super Mario Odyssey captures something magical
that the best Nintendo games typically do.
Reviews called it one of Nintendo's greatest
gaming achievements ever.
That's some pretty high praise for the legendary
studio.
It's a shame the GameCube didn't sell better,
as it housed a few incredible games during
its lifespan.
About a year after the console's original
release, it saw one of its best ever, and
a welcome return to form for a Nintendo legend:
Metroid Prime.
Metroid Prime showed that the legendary Samus
could do a first-person shooter just as well
as she could do a side-scrolling platformer,
and marked the first game in the series in
nearly a decade.
Metroid Prime didn't miss a beat though, and
helped showcase just how powerful the GameCube
hardware was with its impressive visuals and
expansive world to explore.
Metroid Prime is praised on almost every level
for its design, mechanics, and storytelling.
It’s been called a must-have masterpiece.
Fans have seen other Metroid games since,
but few have reached the highs the first Metroid
Prime maintained throughout its playtime.
GoldenEye was a tough game to follow up, but
Rare outdid itself with its spiritual successor,
Perfect Dark.
Anyone who spent hours in the world of James
Bond would feel right at home in the world
of Joanna Dark, and the additions it made
to the already great existing formula helped
solidify Perfect Dark as one of the Nintendo
64's crowning achievements.
There is just so much good in Perfect Dark
that it's tough to focus on specific elements.
GoldenEye's multiplayer came back better than
ever, with a huge array of weapons and modes,
ingenious level design, and even AI-controlled
bots.
The single-player story weaved a cheesy and
engrossing sci-fi yarn, complete with an alien
buddy named Elvis.
"What's wrong?"
"I have a headache.
And with a head this big, that's no joke."
Almost every review of Perfect Dark features
some variation of "Like GoldenEye, but better
in every way."
That's certainly praise enough to land it
on the list of all-time greats.
There are a substantial number of games from
The Legend of Zelda series that are considered
"near perfect," and the latest is no exception.
After Nintendo squandered a bit of its goodwill
towards gamers with the confusing marketing
approach to the Wii U, the Nintendo Switch
was the company's chance to get back in the
game.
Luckily, there was a launch day game worthy
of some hype: The absolutely breathtaking
The Legend of Zelda: Breath of the Wild.
Reviews praised Breath of the Wild for nailing
mechanics from other open world games, but
also being willing to experiment and take
chances.
It really is unlike any other game in the
franchise before it, and most of the criticisms
of the game are minimal and nitpicky.
Breath of the Wild is one of those games that
everyone who owns a Nintendo Switch should
have a go at.
Nintendo has often taken some bold leaps in
introducing new mechanics to its flagship
properties, and Super Mario Galaxy was one
of its biggest yet.
It essentially took the formula set by Super
Mario 64 and perfected it for the motion control
scheme of the Wii.
The game still stands as one of the most innovative
and best uses of the console's hardware ever
released.
Super Mario Galaxy just presses all the right
buttons.
It's a game that Destructoid gushed over by
saying:
"This is the first game on the Wii that I
can recommend without hesitation to gamers
of any stock, from any background — a truly
must-own title.
[It] improves upon flaws in Mario 64 that
I hadn't even noticed until…Galaxy did it
better."
If you're lucky enough to have a Wii or Wii
U sitting around, or if you managed to grab
Super Mario 3D All-Stars for Switch before
it disappeared, this is definitely a game
you should play.
Ever since the series was reinvented with
its third installment, the Grand Theft Auto
franchise has reigned as one of the most popular
in all of gaming.
The most recent release, Grand Theft Auto
5, executes almost everything the series is
known for perfectly.
It's equal parts crime simulator, life simulator,
and incredible tech demo.
At the time of its release, IGN said of GTA5:
"It represents a refinement of everything
that GTA IV brought to the table five years
ago.
It's technically more accomplished in every
conceivable way, but it's also tremendously
ambitious in its own right."
The three-pronged approach to the story, featuring
wildly different protagonists, incredible
attention to detail, and the sheer amount
of stuff hidden in the world make it hard
to load up GTA5 and not get a smile on your
face.
"We might have to chop you up into little
pieces before spraying your pulp mess down
the drain, but I really hope it doesn't come
to that."
The release of Red Dead Redemption 2 was one
of the most anticipated game releases of recent
memory, and a lot of people weren't sure it
could live up to the hype and high bar set
by the previous title.
Rockstar Games delivered far above most players'
expectations, with one of the best examples
of open world gameplay seen to date.
Like Rockstar's other big series, part of
what makes Red Dead Redemption 2 so incredible
is how alive the world feels.
Riding your horse through the wilderness,
it seems like you're just a tiny part of a
living, breathing universe and that you might
stumble across something new at any moment.
It's one of those games that is greater than
the sum of its parts, and truly stands as
an "experience" that everyone interested in
gaming should have.
Until Super Mario Galaxy 2 debuted, Nintendo
hadn’t released a direct sequel to a Super
Mario game in almost twenty years.
It speaks to how frequently Nintendo tries
to stretch the boundaries with its red-capped
mascot, and it also shows just how imaginative
the original Super Mario Galaxy was.
It contained enough new ideas to spawn a follow-up.
Super Mario Galaxy 2 isn't particularly innovative,
but it's another of those "just plain fun"
games where you can't really describe what
makes it so good.
It takes the already impressive gameplay of
the previous game and makes it even better.
Despite the popularity of franchises like
Street Fighter and Tekken, the highest-rated
fighting game on Metacritic actually comes
from a different franchise: SoulCalibur.
Though SoulCalibur is not the original game
in the franchise, that would be Soul Edge,
it was the first to get a major release and
was one of the heaviest hitters in the early
lineup of the Sega Dreamcast.
The franchise has had some strong releases
since this game hit the Dreamcast in 1999,
but none have been quite so impactful.
It truly showcased the Dreamcast's hardware
in a magnificent way, as nearly every review
of the game touched on how incredible it looked
at the time.
It was largely seen as the best reason to
own a Sega Dreamcast, and continues to hold
up as one of the finest examples of a 3D fighter
ever released.
Grand Theft Auto 4 could probably stake a
claim as one of the most influential games
of all time.
Returning to Liberty City in GTA4 was, quite
literally, a whole new world.
Every NPC seemingly had an agenda, and there
is such a huge variety of things to do that
you could put hundreds of hours into GTA4
and still discover new things along the way.
On top of all that, it implemented several
multiplayer modes that, while not quite as
extensive as what's now seen in GTA Online,
surely paved the way for what the series would
become.
"War is where the young and stupid are tricked
by the old and bitter into killing each other."
GameSpot's review of GTA4 summed it up nicely:
"Grand Theft Auto IV is a game that you simply
have to play."
There is a certain subset of gamers who, when
reading anything about the Tony Hawk Pro Skater
franchise, will immediately start humming
or singing.
Chances are, that song comes from the soundtrack
of Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2, universally viewed
as the high point of the series.
The first Pro Skater game laid the groundwork
and capitalized on the rising popularity of
extreme sports to make for a memorable romp
through some wild skate parks.
However, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2 raised the
bar by a huge margin.
It’s the highest rated game ever released
for the PlayStation.
Which is an incredible feat when you remember
just how many revolutionary games came out
for the console.
Metacritic's records go back over two decades,
and tens of thousands of video game reviews
run through its ranking system.
Only one game on the entire website has a
99 rating: The Legend of Zelda: Ocarina of
Time.
The Nintendo 64 was home to several reinventions
of classic franchises, but Ocarina of Time
stands out as the true masterpiece of N64's
library.
The hype surrounding Ocarina of Time, or "Zelda
64" as it was often called, was immense.
And yet, somehow, it delivered and exceeded
almost everything gamers were hoping for.
In the IGN review for Ocarina of Time, the
site wrote:
"When the final version of Zelda 64 arrived
in the IGN64 offices, we stopped working,
locked ourselves into a room with a big-screen
TV and a surround system and played 17 hours
straight.
After only a few hours of sleep, we were back
for more and we couldn't stop until we finished
the game.
Then, we started over again to find all the
secrets."
There is almost no fault to be found in Ocarina
of Time, and it sets an incredibly high bar
for the genre to this day.
It's practically perfect, and thus stands
alone atop the list.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
video games are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.